[Music]
oh wait wait wait sorry before we get
into that do you want we should talk
about the lap dance first okay
just because we're on subject of like
horned up and
whatever yeah when are we not honestly
yeah yeah i feel so bad for mary
why
in the mermaid outfit oh yeah that oh
that was the most
they really did her dirty they did not
help her out yeah
they were like what about something that
covers your whole body yeah and you want
me like straddle people with it like
yeah we'll cut one side of the dress
you know but figure out the other side
she's just like
they
they really did they they picked the
hardest
disney princess to make sexy on land
yeah i'm surprised i didn't give her
like scuba flippers just to make it that
much more difficult yeah
painted to match the [ __ ] dress and
they're like give a lap dance in that
and a scuba yeah and like a [ __ ]
goggles and
a
full-on snorkeling kit
yeah it was funny because like even in
the talking head
like room where they have the dudes go
in and the producers like just see how
horny you were when they came out yeah
and what's the what's the guy's name the
football player that she's with yeah
what's his name again aaron aaron oh and
i was like he's not winning any grammys
yeah
yeah when mary came out i mean like i
was so turned on
she was so sexy
i said grammy's man i meant
[ __ ] no you you win a grammy for that
yeah you think
i don't think no not oscar yeah grammy
yeah
yeah and the most [ __ ] thing we've
heard all year
[Applause]
and the biggest pile of [ __ ] we've
listened to this year erin
oh yeah dude i was so turned on when she
came out
wrapped up like some leftovers
and that green saran wrap dude
[ __ ] yeah so hot
and she's got she's got a full head of
hair so to put another full head of hair
on top that was just rude yeah just
you know yeah everyone else was ass
naked literally ass naked yeah
maybe she made a request she was like
look man i'm not comfortable
putting it down there like that maybe
they're like okay point and they
punished her oh you want to hide
all right [ __ ]
mermaid yeah mean it's mean
maybe she just like wasn't ratting
enough yeah yeah
dude enough six nine behavior
exactly
i know we say this every year but could
you imagine one of us going out in the
midst of those dudes
no like a 5 8 guy just goes out and he's
like hey
i can't believe
yeah
i'm going to do my best
just looking like an emoji
yeah and all the girls are sitting there
just like
how's that
get this little man
[Music]
they're taller than you sitting down
around the fire pit so you're like
dancing up at them
yeah
my hairy chubs in it like my [ __ ]
blubber on my head and her kneecaps yeah
how's that
how's that wait take a grab with these
love handles yeah
yeah you feel that
yeah
thicker than my penis hold on to those
that's right
daddy comes with a built-in diaper
baby comes with a built-in diaper
get a feel for that just because they
can just like hoist you up with you
with the size of your gut hell yeah baby
oh oh wait a minute
you ever seen this much hair on an ass
oh wait a minute what's what's this
oh that's lunch that's what that is
that was lunch
you're just you're used to little little
boy cheeks yeah look at these man cheeks
you see that
oh i gotta sift through the forest
oh
how about this what's up with this back
here what do you think of that
that's how you go out there manly like
you got like a [ __ ] eight-year-old
concept of manliness you're bragging
about all the hair on your body they're
like no
what
look at that
none of these guys here have ass like
that
[Music]
they're always like grabbing each
other's hands and like putting them on
their butt yeah grab your hand just
twist it up in your back hair oh
oh it was tangled up in there
you got your [ __ ] butt crack hair
braided
pull on them
pull on that milly
i need to tap kaz to help you out
because that's a lot of hair she's like
no [ __ ] come on pull on that one pull on
it
don't be scared come on pulling it come
on pull on daddy's horse that's on that
for you oh don't be scared come on pull
on it
oh she's scared
she doesn't want to pull on the ass
break come on she's like i don't want to
just look at the producers
i just picture the
they had a five to five eight dude on
there he'd come out like mr tumnus from
you know little centaur like they'd give
him hooves and [ __ ] and a little pen
pipe flute they're like yeah go out
there like that man he's like
they're [ __ ] frolicking
[Laughter]
i also pictured a short guy going on
there and taking it way too seriously
like being way too good at dancing yeah
he can like pop and lock he's like like
a [ __ ] jabberwocky out there by
himself they're like uh
it's not really that hot it's kind of
good though
i got to see him doing a backflip and
split they're like
i mean i don't
i'm just doing street performer [ __ ]
guys i need all the guys to line up out
here i'm going to jump over all this guy
comes out completely painted gold and
just stands there perfectly still
[Music]
you got the little whistle in his mouth
they're like uh
they're gonna do something
points to he like takes his hat off he
puts it on the ground it's like put a
dollar in there like oh
does anyone go
throw it in the hat and then [ __ ]
playing egyptian lover some old ass hip
hop [ __ ] he just
this is a talent show right
damn
so that's what we would do
painted solid gold
with a [ __ ]
oh my god with a collection hat
and a robotic whistle man jesus christ
he was the sexiest human statue i've
ever seen
[Laughter]
[ __ ] teddy's dance killed me because
his face was so
innocent but he was just banging [ __ ] in
their face yeah like he's just like i
know he's just like all smiles and he
hops
[Music]
i know it was really intense it was
really intense and then what was it
millie in the interview room she or
someone was like yeah it was me
yeah she's like i love looking at his
phd yeah and if you don't already fit
it's not anything to do with school we
know yeah no we know yeah
i didn't know actually
i was like what does that mean
um and kelsey was like i think he's
pretty huge dick and i was like ah
oh dude never hurt never heard that
before no dude it means [ __ ] hurting
device
[Laughter]
yeah he was
slinging dick yeah it was just like just
and everything all the girls were like
like
you remember what faye said what did you
say he's like my mouth is watering this
is embarrassing i was like that's crazy
i've never
heard of a woman like
uh uh salivating yeah after getting
cocked banged in their face that is
nuts man i've never been a male stripper
so maybe it's a comment yeah yeah yeah
she was like my mouth if i would if i
was though
i mean my back hair yeah yeah yeah i'd
be going crazy yeah
if my mouth was watering
over the
upper shoulder hair
he has
pictured
squatting like having being a dude
having the biggest ass on the show so
when you bend over you look like a horse
and like your braided ass cheeks hair
just looks like a horse's tail
you're like pull on it
ride the stallion mama
come on come on i know this is what you
guys really like yeah baby
you know zorro wish he could ride a
horse like this [ __ ]
yeah so
who do you think have the best lap dance
who do you think are the best life dance
better not say a girl otherwise you'll
get in trouble
you know what
you know who who liam
oh because he did the um
what's the you don't want to go to work
or where yeah that's the outfit they
gave him yeah yeah and he was like
kind of like mary every other guy was
stripping down to like a thong yeah and
he was like no i'm gonna keep jeans on
the whole time yeah and he killed it
yeah and then the whole stripper move
where he
yeah hoisted millie up yep that whole
[ __ ] yep
that you know
we could get into the j drama but that
that like uh tekken move he did to
liberty i thought he broke her kneecaps
what did he do when he like laid her on
her stomach and then he like interlocked
his leg yeah
yeah
yeah because that moment where he like
really thrust didn't really go too
smoothly no and she was kind of like wow
yeah yeah yeah and i was like my eyes
liberty's toys
this is going to show
this is going to show up on the joe
rogan podcast he's gonna be look at the
way he interlocks
his ankles that's good
look at the way he locks his legs
wow
wow wow
yeah that that whole move was crazy and
then
mary was you know in the booth she was
like he could be a male stripper yeah
i'm like i mean yeah those moves yeah
pretty [ __ ] intense yeah
sorry i just thought about like i think
he was or something i don't know how you
know how to do that [ __ ] if you weren't
yeah
yeah
no i just thought of i'm just laughing
at the idea of
some like weenie-ass married couples on
the couch
and all the all the wives being like who
do you guys think had the best dance all
dudes like um
uh
tyler yeah tyler was the best yeah the
girls aren't even that good at it
honestly yeah the guys really did a
great job like the girls won but i think
the dudes won yeah way better yeah
the dude's one better
yeah
for sure
yeah not like not even any of the girls
are really that sexy honestly
you